m EPS expressed their shark over the
revelation that the United States has
been running a surveillance program to
gather emails documents video and voice
chats photos and other material from
social media sites the program called
prism is targeted at non Americans
including EU companies some MEP sphere
that several governments are being
complicit and say it will affect the
eu-us investment and trade deal
politicians will be more reluctant also
citizens will be more critically about
having agreements with the US if we
again and again see that at least the
spirit of such agreements are violated
safer food for babies and people with
specialist dietary needs that's the hope
following the adoption of an agreement
between the Parliament and member state
governments clearer labeling is the key
with a ban on the use of baby pictures
on products for those under a year old
but some Emmy peas are angry that baby
who'd can still use crops grown using
agro chemicals that leave a residue it
was a step government ministers refused
to take I wanted to have a complete ban
for the most toxic chemicals known to
man such as cancer genic reproduction
toxic and hormone disrupting chemicals
that they should not be able to use such
pesticides when you produce baby food
but unfortunately the council fought
vigorously that these chemicals can be
put on the fields on foods that is
destined for our children the most
vulnerable group in society
the rise of Euro skepticism engendered
by the economic crisis must not be
allowed to succeed that was part of the
message in a speech to members by the
President of Slovenia former MEP borut
pahor on an official visit he urged a
shared responsibility SPO purple aqua
there is a knowledge that nobody can
tackle these problems on their own but
we can do it together and maintaining
this faith is our primary task